foreign
you're leaving work okay okay
and things got compromised out in the
world you were at work you're doing a
podcast episode or something and like
things are getting like a wall right and
then everything The Purge right what do
you do like how do you this is the end
this is when it's like all right Joe
Rogan you have 90 minutes before that
you're gonna start to feel some pressure
what do you do
I guess load up some magazine oh I'm
[ __ ] but I'm wondering what do you do
you know that's what I would do I'd
probably load up some magazines okay
into what
into guns okay okay okay yeah I see I
don't know if I can no at the
periodicals like Sports Illustrated
this guy's taking information
yeah dude I'm like I just see Yo with
his many copies of Field and Stream as
you can [ __ ] live well you could use
those magazines as like protection you
stack enough of them okay so each other
okay now you're thinking slow bullets
down okay but say like you pick up your
family or something do you guys stay do
you have a bunker
I don't currently but this conversation
is making me want to Bunker yeah yeah
okay what about if you're kind of in a
city or you're um like what's maybe a
business or something you'd hold up in a
business that I'd hold up in it would
have to be some sort of fortified
establishment like the mall no
dude the mall
yeah the mall think of all you could
hide in the [ __ ] Macy's behind all
the hiding Cinnabon behind the camera
just squeezing Frost into your mouth
[ __ ] you pumping shells it would be a
good excuse to eat that food because
like I gotta eat something and that
stuff will keep because a lot of that
stuff has like all the um preservatives
preservatives in it so you'd have that
you'd have mannequins in there think
about that you could set up like a
mirage right right right like a fake
sort of situation yeah where people
would think that but you're behind that
yeah yeah so the mall I think could be
good
I would go to the mall really yeah the
mall yeah because nobody's at the mall
anymore but the dumbest people are at
the mall they're gonna [ __ ] it up for
you they gotta go They're gonna go to
Russia
okay shut the [ __ ] up I'm pretending to
be a mannequin
I'm like hey give me a medium